it's have a look at ten okay now tens
the weird one I tried a small version of
ten over here but I thought I wouldn't
pre-prepare it because it's worth you
learning how to draw it and you know
roughly enough that you can use it to
solve an equation but quite quickly as
well okay so you're gonna step you
through rather than like a slow process
of working on what tear looks like i'm
gonna show you how i graph it roughly
okay so the first thing you should start
with is a clean set axes right i only
have the right hand side of my axes
because have a look at it I get told
that the angle I mapped on and by the
way it's theater here it's X here no big
deal it's just a label okay you can call
that able anything you love you can call
it tan of David or take them from
vehicle whatever it's just a label okay
so I have this angle it's going to be
between naught and 360 these are all
positive right and that's why I've only
got the positive side here's what I'm
gonna do kill however long that you've
drawn it right your set of axes your
horizontal path that's your theta axis
however long you've drawn it just put a
mark in near the end okay that marks
gonna be your 360 degree mark okay
you've all about different size graph so
I can't tell you it'll be five
centimeters long or ten centimeters long
but however far along just so you have a
bit of a gap so I can stop so that guy's
going to be 360 now just like with sine
and cosine all the important points are
these kinds of angles here 90 180 270
without a room on your table look at
your pages say I can know where halfway
is people can generally know it half
ways with some accuracy my halfway looks
about there okay and half of 360 of
course is 180 right so there's 180
once I had that half I need to do this
Harvey this bisecting thing two more
times right one here and one here
that'll give me 90 and 270 so you
quickly bisect
okay
by sector 7 now those two angles that I
just put in 90 and 270 that's where
these Rito vertical dotted lines coming
does anyone remember what they caught
this up of a name
they're called asymptotes very good
they're these special places where the
graph on Alice anyway it can't exist
right you remember it tries to get
closer and closer and closer but it
never gets there
you can't put 1090 into a calculator
it'll just say forget it I'm going alone
you know I quit okay
same with 270 so those 92 seven we just
put in maybe get your app and let's put
those dotted lines those asymptotes
okay once you've got that you've got all
the important pieces and now the fun bit
okay we don't want to put in these three
sections of tenants and they're all
broken apart okay so you can start at
zero start at zero okay and then you're
just drawing the shape so that it goes
up to that first asymptote okay I point
out to you that just like with sine x
and cos x see how when they go through
the axis they're not going through
vertically and they're not going through
horizontally they're going at an angle
okay so you can see I haven't going off
an enabler okay in fact that it was
about 45 degrees that same shape I'm
going to copy over to here right and the
reason I just copy it is because just
like sine a cosine 10 is periodic it
just repeats over again and it repeats
every 180 degrees that's why I went over
up until 80 degrees and then I have this
shape to finish the thing off I'm just
going to do the opposite down here right
so same shape but in the other direction
and then I take this guy and I copy it
same shape going down and voila you have
a perfect looking table like I said
please watch out but when you if you
were to get a rule offer instance if you
get your ruling out and if you try and
line it up so that it lines up with your
tan graph right in the middle like that
can you see my lines going off at an
angle it's going off at an angle it
shouldn't be right there horizontal like
that okay if your graph would look
something like that
go graph looks more like this okay
that's actually the excuse rep it looks
quite different tan graph it blues
straight through every angle so if yours
looks like that maybe drop it out a
little bit so you get this kind of shape
okay it's a very common mistake to make
so it's always make it a few times just
not continuing